Okay.
Once again, I can't believe I have to do this.
Are lies being told by people on the left
about the 2020 Democratic Primary Poles, and
I'm getting endless messages on all platforms
from people who are either telling or believing
the lies saying, David, none of the polls
of the 2020 Democratic primary that showed
Joe Biden leading are accurate.
Why?
Because all of them are polling only old people.
And Joe Biden only does well in polls that
are only of old people and it's just not true.
And I'm going to prove it to you in a second,
but please just stop.
Okay?
I'm not supporting Joe Biden.
I know lots of people in our audience aren't
supporting Joe Biden.
The way to help somebody other than Biden,
when in the primary is not to tell the lie
that the polls are bogus because they're only
a polling old people.
It's just not true.
And it's a real problem that I have to do
this segment today and we're going to talk
through it one piece at a time.
First of all, the people who have lost the
most from Joe Biden running, uh, who were
pulling more than one or two to begin with.
I mean, if you're at an establishment Democrat
who was pulling one or two before Biden announced,
I mean, you're just dead.
Okay, you're done.
But Bernie Warren, Buddha, judge and Beto
are the four candidates who have sort of trailed
in their polling trail off and they're polling
to some degree to differing degrees.
Since Joe Biden made the announcement that
he's running.
Uh, this is, uh, in particular what we have
on the screen showing this from the morning
consult.
Um, uh, Paul, uh, here's their methodology,
which I admit to you is, is sort of opaque.
They say, quote, our Democratic primary results
are reported using 15,000, 770 interviews
with registered voters who indicate they may
vote in the Democratic primary or caucus in
their, for those who say don't know or no
opinion, they're asked to pick a candidate.
They are leaning towards results are reported
among first choice.
And those who lean towards a candidate, the
interviews were collected from April 29 to
may five, margin of error of 1%.
Okay?
So if we look at this one, they're not exactly
giving us, they're not giving us at all the
age demographics and sampling.
They are including people who say they are
supporting a candidate and those who say they're
not sure if they're voting, but if they did,
here's the can that they're leaning towards.
So let's just forget about the morning consult
poll altogether.
Okay.
Uh, let's look at the hill.
Harris X, Paul, which was conducted from may
three to four up with a thousand registered
voters and a nationally representative sample.
The results are very similar to others.
In fact, they're even better for Joe Biden.
Biden is up big, followed by Bernie Mayor
Pete, and then Elizabeth Warren and checkout
the age sampling.
Now, it's true that Biden does it better with
old people than he does with young people.
But this is a proper age sample.
So unless you believe that they're lying about
the age sampling, um, it is not something
that we benefit from.
To claim that Biden is only leading when you
only pull old people.
Let's look at another recent poll.
The Harvard Harris Poll published on May 1st,
which has Joe Biden at 44%.
You once again look at the sampling and there's
proper sampling of gender.
There's proper sampling of education and race
and political party and political ideology
and age.
Okay, so listen, I want a progressive to win
the primary.
I'm not supporting Joe Biden.
I'm not trying to help Joe Biden when, if
we want a progressive to win lying that the
polls with Biden ahead, don't pull young people
is not going to help get somebody else, uh,
elected as the Democratic nominee, uh, over
Joe Biden make the case that young people
and old people should support somebody who
is more progressive than Joe Biden.
Okay?
That's a real conversation that we can actually
have and we can win on the issues.
Talk about why these age divisions exist.
Why is it that Joe Biden does less and less
well with younger and younger groups?
But what do we gain by just making up that
Biden's lead is only because they are pulling
only old people.
I just showed you two recent polls were Biden
is crushing and they, they polled young people,
they have a proper representative age sample.
It's not true and it doesn't help us get a
progressive elected to claim that the polls
are only polling old people.
So just stop saying it.
Okay, here's the data.
Let's actually make issue based arguments
about who, who we should be supporting.